[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la liste est lui en cours pour tous 2020
c'est une équipe qui est diverse dans
ses preuves dans ces parcours dans ses
engagements
elle est renouvelée aussi aux deux tiers
c'est important de dire ce sont tous des
femmes et des hommes qui ont montré par
le passé leur engagement pour l'intérêt
général en général et pour les clients
courtois en particulier c'est une équipe
aussi qui se reconnaît dans des valeurs
fortes des valeurs de gauche voilà car
nous sommes une liste de gauche et non
pas sans étiquette comme certains
d'autres le disent
[Applaudissements]
ce programme nous l'avons voulu lisible
cohérent et réalisable il est articulé
autour de valeurs telles que la
solidarité l'éducation et une volonté de
renforcer également nos actions dans le
domaine de la transition écologique
alors pour illustrer ces valeurs nous
agirons pour que chacun puisse continuer
à vivre à guyancourt notamment au
travers des équilibres dans l'habitat
par exemple mais aussi dans l'est dans
les équilibres entre espaces verts et
espaces habités et également de sur des
points qui ont fait effectivement leurs
preuves telles que le maintien par
exemple de la scolarisation des enfants
de moins de 3 ans j'ai été sollicité
mais pas d'essai soeur également très de
manière très récurrent par l'éducation
nationale pour ouvrir les écoles
habituellement la première semaine du
mois de juillet la dernière du mois
d'août pour des stages de remise à
niveau nous sommes toujours refusé cette
année je vais le faire effectivement
parce que je trouve que c'est une année
particulière et que certains élèves en
auront besoin
la deuxième décision que je vais prendre
c'est une réelle programmation
culturelle ludique et événementiel pour
l'été elle dit en cour parce que là
encore une fois très probablement que
certaines personnes qui habituellement
parc en vacances ne vont pas partir et
enfin dans un délai peut-être plus un
petit peu plus lointain mais pas très
lointain nous allons mettre en place les
groupes actions projets dont qui sont
des groupes de travail qui mêle élus
services de la ville et habitants pour
effectivement un certain nombre de
projets est l'un de ces projets
pourraient être par exemple le bassin
lewig au bout du mcb et soul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]